what is the meaning of life are we here
for a reason is there a point to any of
this and why does food tastes so much
better in the trash this was me and then
this was me then I came back as this
little guy a lot of lives for one dog to
live but I'm getting ahead of myself
let's start at the beginning I'm a new
soul for me it all began with a boy his
name was Ethan Bailey Bailey Bailey
Vince my name was Bailey Bailey Bailey
Bailey oh come on Bailey do it what does
he want from me know whenever life got
Ethan down I knew exactly what to do
ready I'm ready now played with that
ball all afternoon even loved it
[Music]
sometimes he just needed a little nudge
oh wow sorry that was the dog that
wasn't me maybe you should teach your
dog some manners we spent every day
together they fighting over food know
nothing of men as the years went by I
could tell my time with Ethan was coming
to an end good boy Billy I miss you and
then it happened I was back I didn't
have it I'm a girl good girl good girl I
had a new purpose I was needed again and
again and again hi with each new life I
was learning a new lesson fight hmm have
we met before there did you find that
okay ready
[Music]
I tried to make sense out of all the
things I'd see was there a point to this
journey of mine and how did they can fit
in
if i can get you licking and loving I
have my purpose
even why do you always have his dog with
you like a girlfriend replacement or
something the dogs laughing at you dogs
don't black that's funny
[Music]